yo what's up everybody this is
international master Daniel wrench back
again with chest comm here on our
YouTube channel today we're going to
jump right into the greatest chess
players in the history of our game
series the first player I'd like to
cover is the infamous and genius both
infamous for his brilliance on the board
and his antics off the board that being
Robert James Fischer the only American
chess world champion and what I'd like
to do here instead of showing one
complete-game as there were so many to
choose from
instead I decided that showing three of
my favourite Fischer moments three of in
my opinion his greatest combinations
might be the best idea so let's do this
thing and jump right in Robert James
Fischer was an incredible specimen of
chess player someone who changed the
game we always have arguments you hear
players talk about who's the greatest
chess player of all time you know the
most talented chess players we talk
about kappa blanka you hear fischer
mentioned obviously Kasparov and the
most reasonable champion of this wanteth
on and on from India and unfortunately
it's an impossible question to answer
like in every other sport we don't have
time machine or time travel yet so
having these players face each other in
a matches is obviously not a possible
option but I will say that in most
people's opinion Bobby Fischer and Garry
Kasparov separate themselves mainly
because of their dominance over their
particular generation we can't compare
champions from from different
generations to each other but we can
compare their dominance over the players
of their generation and Bobby Fischer
changed the game in terms of preparation
in terms of his dedication to the game
he's famous for quotes that just prove
that he was on another level in terms of
his love for the game and his fighting
spirit and the things that he was able
to achieve as far as match play against
the dominant Soviet players of the time
I'm you're going to see more videos in
this series about Bobby Fischer and what
he was able to accomplish but like I
said I'd like to show three of my
favorite Fischer moments three of my
favor of Fischer combinations things
that he did that I had never seen before
until I saw these games and haven't seen
things completely similar since then so
here we have a game where he was facing
off against James T Sherwin who was a
very strong American player in the
if DS this game is from 1957 Bobby
Fischer has just played the move rook to
a7 with the intention of attacking the
a4 pawn and black chose to follow that
with the move Knight to g4 unleashing an
attack on the bishop on c3 as well as
preparing potential meeting threats on
the King side at first glance most
players evaluate this position as wildly
unclear with white perhaps thinking he
might have to settle on capturing here
allowing black to capture with the
knight and potentially removing this
strong Bishop on d5 however Fischer had
already been prepared for this idea
coming for black and prepared a very
special combination that I really
enjoyed seeing for the first time that
move was rook takes a4 anticipating the
black would capture on c3 and win his
pawn back however in this position fish
are Unleashed something I had never seen
before in a chess game I hope everyone
else enjoys it too Bobby Fischer played
the move rook takes f7 absolute insanity
as it loses in one move to the rook to
c1 check how can he get away with this
move the reason he can is because of the
brilliant Queen f1 double X clam an
absolutely incredible move unleashing a
counter combination a counter discovered
check to his own back rank checkmate an
absolutely incredible move for people to
understand because not only does it does
it play off this potential discovered
check it threatens so many things
including rook takes FA checkmate and
the incredibly unfathomable move that
was played in the game Queen takes c1
double X claim again taking advantage of
the fact that this move doesn't work due
to rook f1 discovered check picking up
the Queen and finishing the game up an
entire rook absolutely incredible stuff
from our champion Bobby Fischer and the
game finished with quick discovered
checks defending of checkmate and
eventually the bishop coming here to
threaten checkmate in a couple moves the
game was over now before we get to one
of our most famous examples the game of
the century with Donald Byrne last here
I'd like to show a positional
combination favorite of mine Bobby
Fischer playing Bishop takes b6 and 9 to
d5 cementing an absolutely beautiful
brilliant piece on the d5 square but
even more so he had the discipline not
to capture on e7 due to an incredible
combination if Knight takes c7 and Queen
takes d6 the move rook F to d8
sacrificing the Queen
for a counter checkmate a background
check mate would have been an incredible
counter shot for his opponent Bobby
Fischer understood that this
prophylactic had prophylactic thinking
to see his opponents threat and instead
continue with an attack on the kingside
winning the game and rather very nice
fashion after the pieces developed
toward the Kings side and blood and
white wins with a crushing attack
against Blacks King as we see here and
finally no game collection or review of
Bobby Fischer's brilliance could be
complete without the game of the century
here Bobby Fischer the young Bobby
Fischer only 13 years of age playing
Donald Byrne considered a much stronger
player at the time Unleashed one of the
most brilliant combinations in the
history of chess starting with the move
Knight to a4 double X clam a completely
unheard-of piece sacrifice removing it a
critical defender of white center with
this double attack on the Queen and
Knight hard to call a double attack when
a piece is simply hanging but after a
force combination of eliminating the
knight on f3 black would win back his
piece up a pawn therefore Donald Byrne
made the correct decision to retreat the
Queen and after Knight takes c3 B takes
c3 figured that his young opponent would
not have the courage to capture the e4
pawn due to this obvious fork of the
Queen and rook how wrong he was when the
young Fischer had seen much deeper than
him Queen to b6 Bishop to c4 Knight
takes c3 an incredible move that Fischer
shows his awareness of where the game is
headed much much deeper than his then
has much more mature and perhaps
stronger opponent understanding the
whites king in the center is a much
bigger weakness than he realizes
forcing play to open up along the e-file
Robert burned I mean excuse me Donald
Byrne decided not to capture here due to
the pin followed by winning back
material and instead after Bishop c5
rookie a check
we saw Bishop to e6 an incredible
combination blacks sacrificing the Queen
on b6 for a4 series of moves and where
in which black wins an incredible amount
of material in an in compensation for
the Queen we see a multiple series of
discovered checks on this King on f1 and
finally after capturing back the bishop
on b6 we see the blacks pieces are
simply too much for the white King to
hold off and this type of position with
a huge amount of material and
compensation for the Queen was only a
matter of time before mating attack
ensued and now we saw the climax of this
position with an incredible series of
force checks walking the King to the
edge of the board until finally the
force checkmate ends with rook to c2 the
last seven moves being completely forced
leading to this force checkmate we hope
you enjoyed this incredible display of
Bobby Fischer's brilliance hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll see you
around on chess calm